seriously before you even know it I'm
gonna have an entire zoo on my
nightstand animal control help
everybody's got a question
hey hey I can ask idea hey welcome to
another episode of ask IJ where I answer
all of your questions
all right from our Twitter question
we've got Jared yow know Jared yeah
bottom of my mama da bah bah bah bah bah
bah bit about my pop asking if I'd ever
willingly use a Microsoft product well
Jared it's kind of interesting that you
would even bring that up because as of
today April 1st
I am a new PC user look at that 2
buttons it's amazing Apple why didn't
you think of it from now on you can just
call me PC Justine cuz guess what drop
in the eye and you know what else
no more iPhone either oh hold on I'm
getting a call
hello oh uh yeah actually I can't hear
you
so because I didn't do an ask IJ episode
last week that's because I was working
on how to be a video blogger music video
and in the video I talk about drinking a
lot of mater which leads me to a whole
handful of YouTube questions that you
guys are asking why do video bloggers
have to drink lots of water well first
of all it rhymes quite nicely because
when you're talking a lot you get
thirsty you get thirsty and you gotta
drink lots of water because the thirsty
you need to drink these dehydrated and
now back to sanity
and after a video response my question
is how many popsicles six do you think
it would take to make a life-size model
yourself I said that this episode I was
gonna take a Facebook question well the
Facebook question is from Kelly and she
wanted to know why and when did I start
making videos for YouTube well I haven't
always been a youtuber I actually posted
my first video on myspace back on 2005 I
think and here it is the first video
I've ever posted online anywhere and
here's the second video that I've ever
post send it anywhere
bet you guys didn't know that I was such
a pro at doing the Irish jig that's
actually where I used to work when my
boss would leave the office you're not
gonna lie I would dance I'd have a dance
party with myself to see those videos in
their full amazing glory check out
youtube.com slash other iJustine for
some wonderful vintage edgy treats and
that's it for episode 6 make sure to
leave your comments below add your video
responses and don't forget you can ask
questions on twitter and on facebook
check my blog for all of the information
that you might need to know oh we can
happy april fools
I'm still a Mac user